So Leute, ich bin am Start, wisst ihr was?
Ich hab jetzt Urlaub für das restliche Jahr.
Noch keiner da, aber ich dachte mir, ich sag das jetzt einfach mal.
Ich hab exakt legit, Leute, null Zuschauer, oh jetzt drei, jetzt sind die ersten drei
schon da.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ich hab legit null Zuschauer.
Vielleicht ist das auch einfach nur mein Vorschau-Screen, klar, das würde ich auch
sein.
Oh, meine Hände sind kalt.
Bevor wir jetzt eine Runde Battlefield spielen, muss ich auf jeden Fall die Hände aufwärmen.
Sonst ist noch mehr PP-GA-Aim angesagt als gestern.
MonkaSsteer, ja.
So, jetzt sind schon acht Leute da.
Hogchamp.
Ich dachte, ich muss meine Hände ein bisschen aufwärmen, bevor es losgeht.
Sonst wird das nix.
Wie das die krassen Pros halt so machen.
Die Anzeige funktioniert eigentlich nie richtig.
Na doch, doch, geht eigentlich.
Die ist relativ gut, manchmal spackt die, manchmal zeigt die viel zu viel, manchmal
viel zu wenig, aber zum größten Teil geht's eigentlich ganz gut.
Soll ich euch was erzählen, Leute?
Ich hab mir einen neuen Drucker gekauft, so ein Multifunktions-Ding mit Scanner, aber
diesmal Farblazer, Farblazer, also kein eintrocknender Tintenstrahl-Müll.
Und ich wollte das Ding einrichten unter Windows, das hat nicht funktioniert.
Er hat immer nur den Drucker erkannt und nicht den Scanner.
Und jetzt hab ich alle, jetzt hab ich alle Settings durchgetestet, wie man Drucker hinzufügt
unter Windows und eins davon ging, dann hat er beides discovered.
Den Sinn hab ich nicht verstanden, zumal wisst ihr, was mir da aufgefallen ist, ich zeig
es euch mal.
Also, man kann hier in Printer und Scanner gehen, guckt, das ist der neue Drucker, den
ich mir gekauft hab.
Da.
Neuer Drucker.
Und man kann jetzt, passt mal auf, einfach adden geht unter Windows nicht mehr.
Man kann jetzt sagen, Printer not listed und dann hat man hier verschiedene Sachen zur
Auswahl.
So, und ich war so doof, ich war so doof, ich hab's damit probiert, ich hab's damit
probiert, ich hab's damit probiert und ich hab's damit probiert, hat alles funktioniert,
außer das da, da hat er discovered, hat nicht funktioniert, hat alles funktioniert, aber
hat immer nur den Drucker gefunden, nicht den Scanner.
Was ich hätte machen müssen, ist das da auswählen und dann dort die IP vom Drucker eingeben
und auf next drücken, dann hat er beides discovered.
Ist wirklich hardcore hängen geblieben.
Ach ja, und das Scanner dreimal ist auch irgendwie kaputt, ach ich darf gar nicht scannen hier,
auch nice.
GG Eats.
Und wisst ihr was mir aufgefallen ist, der letzte Stream, ja, ach ganz ehrlich, solange
es mich bock macht, spielen wir das jetzt noch ein bisschen, aber wisst ihr was mir aufgefallen
ist, es gibt noch übrig gebliebenes Zeug unter Windows und zwar, guck mal, es gibt
noch den Windows XP Scanner und Kameras Dialog, warum der da ist, ich weiß es nicht.
Ja, das hätte man machen können, aber das Ding hat W-Lan, warum sollte ich es extra
nochmal an irgendeinem Raspberry Pi hängen, macht ja keinen Sinn.
Macht ja wirklich keinen Sinn, passt ja.
So, lasst mal gucken, irgendjemand wollte was wissen, was der neue Job macht?
Ich weiß noch nicht, je nachdem wie lange ich es durchhalte, vielleicht spielen wir
auch bloß 1-2 Stunden Battlefield, da hab ich schon 20, 15, ja vielleicht, ja mal gucken,
mal gucken.
Vielleicht machen wir noch was anderes, aber ich denke wir haben heute bloß Zeit für 2-3
Stunden Battlefield.
Aber ich hab jetzt Urlaub, ich hab Urlaub für das komplette restliche Jahr, das heißt,
ja, können wir jetzt ordentlich streamen und Videos machen und Zeug, es hat sich jemand
bei mir par Mail gemeldet, der gemeint hat, er kann für mich Thumbnails erstellen, das
soll er natürlich nicht umsonst machen, ist ja klar, hab ihm jetzt gefragt, ob er mir
mal 2 Samples machen kann, mit Thumbnails, wo ich nicht zufrieden war, die ich selbst
erstellt hab, ob er so ein bisschen mein Thumbnail Style einfangen kann, aber das halt verbessern,
also dass es eben besser performt, wenn das was wird, lass ich mir gleich im Vorfeld so
10-15 Thumbnails produzieren, nein morgen nicht mehr arbeiten, heute war mein letzter
Tag dieses Jahr, vielleicht der letzte Tag insgesamt, ne der letzte Tag insgesamt wird
es nicht gewesen sein, weil ich muss auf jeden Fall nächstes Jahr noch 3 Monate hin.
DCD Mode, ach Domain Controller, hab ich gar keine Ahnung davon, das Gute ist, ich zeig
euch mal kurz, was ich für einen Drucker bestellt hab, ich hab meinen MFC 37750 CDW,
ok, ich hab mir das Ding gekauft, und das ist halt ein Laser mit Farb, also mit 4 Tonern,
heißt es ja da, bisschen laut, ne geht eigentlich, Lexmark, oh geh mal fort, Lexmark kommt
mir nicht mehr in die Tüte, und mit Scanner, ich eigentlich brauch mal keinen Scanner mehr,
aber ich dachte mir, hey manchmal muss ich doch die ein oder andere Sache noch einscannen,
normalerweise fotografiere ich das, aber gescannt ist die Quali doch ein bisschen besser, und
es hat theoretischen Fax, aber naja, wer wird schon Fax verwenden, Fax, ja in Deutschland
braucht man das, guten Abend zusammen, weiß jemand, wie ich einen Einkommenssteuerbescheid
für ein vergangenes Jahr anfordern kann, mein Finanzamt gefühlt 2 Stunden offen, niemand
geht ans Telefon, kann man das, ich habe keine Ahnung, ich mach das alles mit dem Steuerberater,
genau aus diesem Grund, weil mir alles auf den Sack geht, Leute, Thema auf den Sack gehen,
ich glaub ich hab's euch erzählt sogar schon im letzten Stream, ich hab einen Drucker bei
Amazon bestellt, also den da, den da hab ich bei Amazon bestellt, den Drucker, und die
haben mir erst den falschen Drucker geliefert, die haben mir nämlich nicht den 3750 CDN geliefert,
sondern den 3701 CN, oder so, so und der eine hat Wlan und der andere hat kein Wlan und
sowas, es blickt keiner durch, zumindest, das war verkehrt, genau, magst du, ja ich
hab's euch erzählt, zumindest, das war verkehrt, und dann wollte ich den Drucker wieder zurück
schicken, riesen Paket, Alter Leute, irgendwie 30 Kilo Paket, also gehe ich bei Amazon auf
Retoure, druck mir das DPD Paket auf, bring's in Shop, und der DPD Shop sagt mir, Paket
ist zu schwer, können wir nicht nehmen, schreib ich an DPD und jetzt, weil abholen lassen
daheim geht bei DPD auch nicht, das geht nur, wenn man selbst den Versand beauftragt und
nicht Amazon, dann hat DPD gesagt, Amazon muss den Abholauftrag stellen, dass sie zu
mir heim kommen und das Paket abholen, Amazon hat keinen Plan gehabt, was ich von ihnen
will, also ich hatte quasi ein Drucker und ein Rücksende Etikett, aber ich konnte es
nicht loswerden, und dann hab ich Massive Glück gehabt, ja ich hab's gestern schon
erzählt, ja ich weiß, zumindest ich hab ein DPD Typ, so ein DPD Fahrer auf der Straße
getroffen, konnte zwar kaum ein Wort Deutsch, aber hat das Paket mitgenommen, gescannt,
wunderbar, alles top, und jetzt ist es auf dem Weg, und mein neuer Drucker, der heute
gekommen ist, um noch ein bisschen was von der Story von gestern hinzuzufügen, mein
neuer Drucker, der heute gekommen ist, den hab ich auch über Amazon bestellt, und aus
irgendwelchen Gründen kam der aus Spanien, ich hab jetzt alles auf Spanisch da drauf,
und dann hab ich die Google Translator App genommen und hab die über das Display vom
Drucker gehalten, dass der mir Spanisch auf Deutsch bzw.
Englisch übersetzt, und dann konnte ich, man konnte nur Preset auswählen, Spanisch, Portugiesisch
oder Italienisch, und dann hab ich's auf Italienisch gestellt, und dann hab ich mit
dem Google Translator mich in die Advanced Settings eingedingst, und dort konnte ich
dann umstellen auf Englisch, warum man das den Leuten so schwer macht, kein Plan, nee
wie gesagt, morgen nicht arbeiten, ja, guter Titel, guter Titel, also ich kann euch ja erzählen
was da gewesen ist, also zwei Sachen, die es zum neuen Job gibt, nächste Woche hab
ich nen Termin bei dem neuen Laden, mal gucken ob man sich jetzt da abschließend einig wird,
ob man sich versteht, kann ja immer noch sein, dass wir uns da überhaupt nicht sympathisch
sind, ist irgendwie mit fünf Leuten oder so, Abteilungsleiter, Teamleiter plus den drei
Leuten aus dem Team und sonst wie, das kommt sich ja vor wie in der Befragung, so das ist
nächste Woche, fahr ich da hin, und heute hatte ich nen Termin mit meinem Chef auf der
aktuellen Arbeit, und wie ich schon vermutet habe, die können sowohl Homeoffice technisch
als auch Gehaltstechnisch gerade irgendwie, tun sie sich da sehr schwer, auch wenn sie
sich immer abfeiern, dass alles super erfolgreich ist, aber tun sie schwer, da hab ich mir gedacht,
gut, ich kann euch nicht zwingen mit mir ne ordentliche Homeoffice-Regelung zu machen,
aber ihr könnt mich auch nicht zwingen herzukommen, und deswegen geht Ende des Jahres sehr sehr
wahrscheinlich, wenn das nächste Woche klappt, die Kündigung raus, ich muss noch nicht,
ich warte nur noch, aber ich werde da nicht unterschreiben direkt nächste Woche, erst
mal gucken, ob im Vertrag nicht doch irgendwas drinsteht, was mir nicht gefällt, und ich
habe noch was anderes offen, wo ich warten will, was da rauskommt, ohne Scheiß, Leute,
die brauchen sich überhaupt nicht wundern, wenn die Leute liefen, ich bin jetzt einer
der ersten, die wirklich ernst machen, mit diesem, es geht mir auf den Keks, ich geh
jetzt, die anderen sind nur am meckern, aber das wird über kurz oder lang, auch Dorter
Falzer bin ich mir relativ sicher, und man sagt ja so, die guten gehen zuerst, ich weiß,
das ist indirektes Selbstlob jetzt, aber ich sag mal, die fehligen Leute werden zuerst
gehen, was man auch schon sieht, was willst du machen, wie gesagt, man kann sie nicht
dazu zwingen, das stimmt, deswegen hab ich mir auch so einen gekauft, der hat 450 Euro
gekostet, der Drucker, aber ich hoffe, ich hab jetzt für immer meine Drucker sorgenlos,
das sind keine Tintenstrahler, die verkleben und Müll sind, ja, ganz gut, wird bei dir
ähnlich sein, ja, let's go, nee, alles Aufzeichnung, so, machen wir mal Battlefield an, gucken
wir mal, wie lange ich das durchhau, wer spielt denn heute hier, ah, der gute Opa Peitscher,
El Schmago Fats spielt weiter, Battlefield 3, den hatten wir gestern, den adde ich, den
hatten wir gestern, da hat mich gestern ein paar mal gerest, der Typ, HiAQ Typ, aber hier,
der Opa Peitscher, ich spiel ohne Team, ihr könnt joinen, wenn ihr wollt, wenn ihr zufällig
in Switchmaking kommt, aber ansonsten spiel ich erstmal wie gestern ein paar Runden, hallo,
Game starten please, geht nicht, why, why not, wie gesagt, nicht wundern, es wird erstmal
ein bisschen ruckeln, bis ich das umgestellt hab in OBS, aber so ist es halt, ist halt
leider in dem Spiel so, ha, warte mal ab, du hast am Anfang jetzt noch alles neu, du
wirst feststellen, das Spiel hat kaum Content und es hat sehr viele nervige Sachen, am Anfang,
so die ersten paar Runden ist das cool, aber das lässt schnell nach, also ich denke auch
nicht, dass ich nach dieser Woche noch großartig Bock drauf hab, aber schauen wir mal, Leute,
was wollen wir machen, wollen wir erstmal noch ein paar Runden neue Maps spielen, Breakthrough
oder wollen wir gleich in Rush, komm wir spielen 1-2 Runden, wir spielen 1-2 Runden Breakthrough,
fucken uns da ein bisschen ab, die neue Map, bisschen angucken noch und dann, wir können
auch mal Conquest spielen, aber Conquest 182, ich mags, ich mags nicht, weiß nicht, 1-2
Runden C++ Desktop Application programmieren, naja, C++, ich hab heute auf Hacker News was
gelesen, C++ compilen zu WebAssembly und dann WebAssembly umwandeln zu irgendeiner komischen
Run Anywhere Echse, das Echse, das ist Windows, Run Anywhere Binary, ich hab irgendein Projekt
gesehen auf Hacker News, dass sie es jetzt irgendwie hinbekommen haben, die Browser
WebAssembly Runtime dort auszubauen, dass du damit dann quasi WebAssembly überall laufen
lassen kannst und von jeder Sprache in WebAssembly kompilieren um es dann überall auf, frag mich
nicht warum man das machen soll, aber das geht jetzt, also könnte man theoretisch C++
programmieren und das zu WebAssembly um es dann in einer Browser WebAssembly Runtime
auf dem Desktop laufen zu lassen, ich glaube das ist eine gute Idee oder?
So, das ist immer, Display Capture, hey es funktioniert, nice, einmal kurz die Musik
raus, nein ich will nicht mein Video anmachen, ich will die Musik ausmachen, gut, Laserdrucker
beste, das ist richtig, Hintenstrahldrucker machen oft Probleme, gerade wenn du es eine
Weile nicht verwendest, komm, Moment, wir schauen uns das jetzt mal vorher an, dass wir
heute eine andere Waffe mal spielen, das geht mir auf den Keks, was könnten wir uns denn
machen, Secondary juckt mich nicht, die Vault Waffen sind fast ausschlammslos Müll, das
Ding ist zu Tode genervt, pp29 mal wieder zur Abwechslung, gab es schon eine Weile nicht
mehr, könnten wir tatsächlich mal wieder spielen, ak74, am40 habe ich schon ratet,
sfar, mgl, was haben wir denn hier zum anlocken, m16, die ganz obere smg ist nice, gucken wir
uns gleich mal an, was haben wir so bei lmgs zu bieten, das Ding wurde auch genervt, das
war glaube ich auch ziemlich op am Anfang, es gibt halt einfach nur 4 in dieser Kategorie
gibt, das ist eigentlich, ah das ist das neue Teil, das ist die neue Sniper, ich werde aber
nicht snipern, aber ist das überhaupt ein Sniper, ja das ist so eine Art Sniper, was
ist das, ah ist das, ist das der smg, ok mal ausprobieren, mal ausprobieren, du findest
es blöd, dass die Waffen so random Namen haben, ja da gebe ich dir komplett recht,
das ist ein bisschen wie die lachmann in mp2, auch so ein richtig dummer Name, lachmann,
nenn ich heckler und koch mp5, lachmann smg, wenigstens klingt das noch halbwegs deutsch
lachmann, weil eigentlich klingt eher wie so ein döner oder so, das update ist 57 gigabyte
groß, ah klar, die spiele unter dreistelligem gigabyte macht doch heute keiner mal was,
seit warzone das quasi normalisiert hat, denken die sich alle, warum sollte ich sound komprimieren,
warum sollte ich überhaupt, ich komprimiere einfach gar nichts mehr, einfach alles da
sein und gut ist, der will 57 gigabyte, doch das ist 57 gigabyte, wenn du nicht vorher
schon upgraded hastest, ich hab gestern auch irgendwie 57 gigabyte oder so was runtergeladen,
ja, jep, jetzt können wir uns dieses tolle info angucken, was man sich unbedingt jedes
mal angucken muss, moment, moment, wir wollen das Ding, das Ding oder das Ding, mal gucken,
das Ding hab ich glaub ich noch nie ausprobiert, customize, gibt es nix zu, oh jetzt muss man
den ganzen krempel erstmal wieder anlocken, monka, monkaz, sniper, nein ich sniper nicht,
schönes intro, schönes intro, answichtig, da passiert so viel, wisst ihr, diese roboterarme,
gut dass ich die jetzt gesehen hab, jetzt weiß ich auch wofür ich da dieses gebäude
verteidige, ach borer, borscht professional, moment, ist das gar nicht auto, wait, das
Ding ist, das Ding hat kein auto, feuer, ist ja auch ein marksman rifle, sieht aber eher
aus wie ne smg, deswegen dachte ich, das hat auto, darf ich hier rein, please, wow, nein,
nein, lass mich in Ruhe, ah nice, wanted sniper in the bobs, ok, nee, irgendwelche,
irgendwelche, wo man, wo man aimen muss, das geht nicht, der rettet mich auch keiner,
wisst ihr eine Meinung zu battlefield 5, kann man durchaus spielen, ist das nicht übel,
für mir ist halt der funke über battlefield 5 nicht so richtig übergesprungen, was sagt
ihr, die erste smg ist pork, was auch immer man hier alles so zum ausrüsten hat, aber
immer mal, immer mal das, die dings sind schon hier, was ist da los, das da, das da, das
da, das da, nein, okay, der panzer, nein nein, oh hallo,
Ich bin ja gut, way to dank, geht gut los, der pence man, geht richtig gut los, oh die
haben A1 schon, jetzt wird es aber kritisch hier, kritischer Hase, gehen die auf range
ich sag das, ich sehe schon das klappt hier wieder richtig gut, pass auf da kommt jetzt
da was rein, ich habe mega lag, alter was ist denn das, alter was ist das, ich drücke
auf reload eine halbe sekunde später, reloade das ding irgendwie erst, wtf seht ihr das,
ihr wisst ja nicht, weil ich die Taste drücke, au, was,
ok die SMG macht zumindest ganz gut damage auf close range, die ist ganz ok, kann man
tatsächlich spielen, ah Mist, was habe ich eigentlich als secondary dabei, nix, nee ich
habe nix, doch, doch ich habe motion sensor dabei, gut das wird wieder absoluter clusterfuck
jetzt, dr keck, ja der hat die Chance wirklich verpasst sich keck w zu nennen, den kann ich
nicht rest, dann bin ich down, du spielst das wie der neue season ist passiert, nicht dass
es so viel ändert, ja, ist halt, ist halt wieder komplett, guckt es euch an, einfach so ein
bisschen gelände, noch ein bisschen gelände, heli, kannst du halt nix machen, ich versuche
jetzt mal, ich versuche jetzt mal hier irgendwie zu flanken, aber wahrscheinlich kriege ich
direkt, direkt auf den Sack, oh guck mal da ist schon einer von mir, aha, ok wir können
nicht weiter, ist ja auch nice, das hat richtig gelohnt hier zu flanken, braucht man den season
pass, nee, ach nee, braucht man einen, ist ja, nee, nee, kann glaube ich jeder das gekauft
hat spielen, wäre ja auch bescheuert wenn nicht, du kannst dich an den heli ranpacken, funktioniert
das jetzt gescheit, oh was ist denn hier los, guck mal da, da ist ein auto und wahrscheinlich
müssen wir den motion sensor hinschmeißen, weil da Leute aussteigen, nice, wir müssen
uns das am Anfang erstmal eine runde in breakthrough geben, ganz einfach damit wir nachher rush,
guck mal, ich habe, guck mal, Leute, seriously, ich habe dahin, nee, dahin habe ich geklickt
und ich spawne 90 Meter woanders, da kann man sich auch gleich schenken, dass ich das auswählen
kann, oder, oh, in sack, in sack geschutet, oh motion sensor, jetzt, jetzt bräuchte ich
mal ein bisschen, okay, die checken es nicht, ich bleibe hier liegen, ich bleibe hier liegen,
ich move kein Stück, ich move kein Stück, easy, oh nein, wo wir dann dabei sind, einfach
in der Ecke liegen, beste Taktik, nicht nur in battlefield, in mw2 funktioniert es auch,
wunderbar, einfach den camp champ starten, so zu c1 gehen sie alle, wir gehen rüber,
zu c2 gehen sie alle, wir gehen rüber zu c1, by the way, hier vorne ist ein tunnel, haben
sie sich gedacht, doch nicht so blöd, also die map designer, wenn es da ein bisschen
deckung gebe zwischen den zwei objectives, man muss sich sagen, high IQ time, die waffe
ist nicht so schlecht beim reloaden, bin ich nicht ganz sicher, ob das normal ist, lebt
da dude noch, ich sehe hier nichts, was zum, was ist mit dir los, Achtung, Achtung, Achtung,
lex.
Achtung.
das war aber wirklich knapp
ich kämpfe jetzt ein bisschen und guck dass da nichts rüber kommt
was willst du machen?
by the way es gibt glaube ich keinen weg
ich sag ja irgendwie wie oft will ich noch by the way sagen
man kann nicht aufs dach
funktioniert nicht gescheit
oh pp gott weg pp gott machste nix
aber ihr wisst ich kanns immer auf meine settings schieben
meine settings sind nicht die richtigen
da der bunte gunter hat mich
das sieht überhaupt nicht so bunt aus
ich hätte jetzt mal zumindest irgendwie regenbogenbinde erwartet
oder so wenn der gunter bunt ist
da unten ist er, hier ist er, gunter
geckl
machste nix
warum binde?
na das ist doch grad die diskussion
warum die bei der fußball wm keine regenbogen binde und zeug um haben
da ging es ja oft wieder die letzten tage über hoch her
wie ist das eigentlich ausgegangen? hat irgendjemand geguckt?
ich habe null interesse an fußball aber ich habe mitgekriegt dass wohl die deutschen heute spielen
ging
cute nation
2 zu 1 für ja seriously
wirklich dachte wir sind viel besser als die japaner was fußball angeht
die hatten einfach power of friendship
kannst nix machen aber ohne miss ich dachte eigentlich wir sind wir sind viel besser
also wir das hört sich immer so an als hätte ich damit irgendwas zu tun
ihr wisst wie ich das meine
ja ich dachte der erste ist down aber ist er nicht
fußball ohne rückrad ist schwer
ja da gab es tatsächlich paar lustige memes
wobei ich ehrlich sagen muss
ich weiß nicht
ob man das wirklich quasi
denen da vorwerfen kann
letztendlich sind das
ja wie soll man sagen das ist ihr arbeitsplatz
man kann sicherlich kritisieren warum
das dort stattfindet
beziehungsweise dass die fifa da so arschkriechermäßig unterwegs ist
aber da jetzt den fußball an den vorwurf zu machen ich weiß nicht
letztendlich ist das ihr job
aber
was machen die im server
kobe nades
die pläne läuft
so wir gehen jetzt hier mal auf die andere seite
die rechnen ja mit uns hier
deswegen flanken wir da jetzt weil die damit nicht rechnen
nach mann würde ich mal ein bisschen besser treffen
da hätte ich jetzt alle gekillt
aber wir haben gestern gesehen im stream
im laufe des streams ist es besser geworden
und schon genug container deploy
anscheinend nicht
oh alter was ist hier am eingang
da ist ja riesen auflauf
elotrix fern treffen oder was machen die denn hier
so was was wollen die ganzen leute
am eingang
das war eine ziemlich doofe idee von mir
nein
ich bin auch genau da drüber
gekreppling hockt
als die granate hochgegangen ist
ok wo sind wir
das hat er sich anders vorgestellt glaube
auch hier ist richtig was los drin
aber da vorne da vorne
mann wie viele sind das denn
du kannst ja in keine richtung gucken
ohne dass du da irgendwelche
dass sie mit drei vor dir hast
ja klar der stirbt nicht nö und warum soll er sterben
ok auf range sagt das ding zipp
ok ich brauche motion sensor dass ich mitkrieg was da passiert und ich muss das ding auf burst umstellen
weg pepega pepega
hätte ich easy haben müssen habe ich aber nicht gehabt
mensch
guck mal seht ihr seht ihr wie schlecht ich bin hätte ich ein bisschen
disziplin was
hätte ich ein bisschen disziplin und nicht so dauerfeuer werden die alle
tot gewesen
aber so ist das halt
guck mal zu zugrach geht voll ab
aber wir haben es gut
z 2
wie sieht es bei euch eigentlich aus habt ihr auch mal season 2 ausprobiert
ich habe einen spawnpunkt
habt ihr auch mal season 2 ausprobiert oder reicht es euch was ihr gesehen habt denkt euch nope
muss nicht sein
kommt mir die hinten raus
das ist eine auto nope du hast es nicht gekauft ok verständlich
geht nicht
verständlich
wissen was wir jetzt mal ausprobieren werden leute versuchen jetzt mal ein bisschen zu flanken
falls das funktioniert
wahrscheinlich funktioniert es nicht weil man in dem gelände hier die gegner nicht
sieht aber die ein wahrscheinlich schon mit 50 leuten gespottet haben
nope siehst du
übrigens den heli hast du nicht gehört außer eben kurz worauf mich geballert hat
es ist würde ich sagen
fast ähnlich gut wie das wasson 2 soundsystem
oder auch nichts hörst hat mich gerade der heli getroffen durch die decke oder so
hat aufgegangen da oder jaja jaja achtung achtung
seriously
Seriously
Alter Mensch warum kommt da einer von der Seite grad wo man mal wieder ein bisschen was bashed? Nope
gibt es nicht
Aber wir haben C2 wirklich ganz ganz brauchbar aktuell
Wenn ich jetzt noch reinkomme wäre äußerst
Pogu
Oder Pogu? Es wäre auf jeden Fall nice
Gleich krieg ich nen Rest. Nice Don Theory Nein sehr schön
Da sind noch mehr wir müssen da mal ein Motion Sensor hinhauen das sind einige noch vorne glaube ich
Oh hinter mir
Gachi Bass
Ist das eigentlich Gachi Bass oder Gachi Bass?
Ich fasse es nicht Schild tut man
Alle weggespreit wenn das Schild typisch am Start gewesen wäre. Oh das ist schlecht
Das ist schlecht, weil die haben nur noch 62
Keine Ahnung was hier abgeht ich verpiss mich mal kurz
Die SMG ist hier relativ nice. Leider hat es hier auch so mittlere
Wie? Hä? Wie haben wir das verloren? Wir stehen da mit 50 Leuten drin
Na gut
Das ist jetzt ein bisschen long range-iger. Lass uns mal das da probieren
Ne so so so so so so so ist gut
Excellent
Also ich muss ja sagen ich habe Warzone nur ein paar Runden gespielt das neue. Mir hat es halt gar nicht gefallen
Es hat mir überhaupt keinen Spaß gemacht
Meint ihr ich soll es noch mal ausprobieren?
Was ist das denn?
Wie ist es bei euch? Spielt ihr das gerne? Sollte man sollte man sich das noch mal angucken?
Weil ich meine das kann ich nicht lange spielen hier
Also das kann ich noch ein paar tage spielen dann ist vorbei
Wow, chat was hat mich getroffen? Was ist xm370a?
Das hat übrigens geshakt. Overwatch. Oh Leute mein Wunderpunkt. Ach das ist der neue Airburst Granatenwerfer
Okay das ist tatsächlich gar nicht so blöd weil genau für sowas ist der ja da. Was für eine Waffe spielst du am liebsten?
Aktuell muss ich sagen die hier nachdem sie die SMGs alle genervt haben. Die ist so schön schön universell
Mensch ganze Schneiber Dudes
Dr. Keg hat einfach 50 Kills schon
Hunt. Tatsächlich habe ich es noch nie gespielt
Lucio Skills. Ey ich hätte ja prinzipiell eigentlich schon ein bisschen Bock auf Overwatch
Ein bisschen. Aber auf der anderen Seite Blizzard hat mir so den Spaß an Overwatch verdorben
Mit ihrer Patch Politik und vor allem mit ihrer Balance Philosophie. Ihr kennt ja so das gute alte Blizzard Balancing
Blizzard Balancing ist, könnt ihr euch in WoW und anderen Blizzard Games auch gut angucken
Blizzard Balancing ist ein sehr guter Spiel. Ich finde es auch sehr gut. Ich finde es auch sehr gut
Blizzard Balancing ist, könnt ihr euch in WoW und anderen Blizzard Games auch gut angucken. Blizzard Balancing ist
Ah diese Held ist OP. Wir Patchen den jetzt. Held gepatcht. Held ist Useless
So dann passiert an dem Held erstmal gar nichts
Und dann irgendwann so ein Jahr später kommt hier ein Patch. Ah Held ist wieder OP
Also es gibt quasi bei Blizzard nur OP as fuck oder aber Useless as fuck
So irgendwie normale Sachen gibt es da gar nicht mehr. Die kriegen es nicht gescheit hin
Was zum? Warum? Okay hat irgendjemand einen Plan warum ich gerade in der Luft gespawnt wurde? Ach weil ich am Spawnbeacon rein bin
Verstehe Verstehe Verstehe
Oh guck mal da können wir schön von der Seite rein klatschen jetzt
Gibt es jetzt mehr? Das hier oben ist eigentlich ganz nice
Jetzt musste ich hinter Belsen raus. Da machst du nichts
Das haben sie durchschaut. High IQ Gegner. Way to six head für mich
Wo sind die hier? Sehe was. Wo stellst ihr rum? Gegners
Okay krasser PP-GM. Guck mal die callen schon GG easy easy win
GG gecallt
Der ging rein gerade
Der ging gut rein
Ah shit. Ey guck mal wir haben fast aufgeholt mit Kills
Der Typ hatte vorher noch 14 Kills Vorsprung aber gut aufgeholt
Hast du Spaß an dem Game? Temporär könnte man sagen es kommt so was wie Spaß auf
Mal gucken was sie sagen was ich besonders gut gemacht habe die Runde
Aber Spaß ist eh cringe. Brauchen wir nicht. Wir will schon Spaß in Games haben Mensch
Stell euch das mal vor. Was habe ich denn gemacht? SMG Kills 34
Ey der Typ ging ab. Der Typ hatte 31 Revives und Top Kills also das war eindeutig der MVP
Wisst ihr was ich nicht verstehe so Balancing technisch also jetzt nochmal so im Prinzip
in den meisten Games. Wie schafft das zum Beispiel die ganzen MOBAs? Ja da gibt es
deutlich mehr Helden aber da sind auch nicht alle Helden viable das ist schon klar aber
trotzdem ich habe beispielsweise letztens letztens war in Dota 2 war so ein großes e-sport
Turnier also quasi das größte einmal jährlich weiß ich ob das jemand geguckt hat von euch
hab da ein bisschen reingeschaut und ich habe mir ein bisschen die Statistiken angeguckt
und mir ist aufgefallen dass die meisten Helden irgendwie irgendwo mal gespielt wurden natürlich
hast du trotzdem wieder so deine 20 30 Helden die einfach quasi dauerhaft gepickt werden
aber wir reden hier von 20 30 so Helden die ganz gut gepickt werden ja und nicht irgendwie
4 aber du hast auch geguckt also deswegen die kriegen das auch hin wahrscheinlich mehr
Schrauben ich glaube ja klar du hast mehr Schrauben du kannst an ganz vielen Stellen
drehen und auch nicht nur bei Helden Balance auch bei Respawn Timern und sonst allem aber
ich glaube generell dass die etwas feinfühliger balancen das ganze dass die so nicht dieses
Hop oder Top oder Flop Balancing machen sondern eben das bisschen überlegt haben und vielleicht
auch mal die ein oder anderen Pros das testen lassen in Overwatch haben die Pros ja gesagt
so wirklich großes Blizzard Feedback gibt es da nicht die machen einfach mal was vielleicht
wenn du Glück hast wirst du mal gefragt aber es juckt dann kein so wir sind Attacker jetzt
ok nice was war denn da jetzt das hat gesagt mach mal die nochmal die SMG ach komm wir
machen nochmal die SMG ja bin rein da nach All Seats Occupied na dann warten wir mal
es wäre halt auch cool wenn man das schon also man kann das customize direkt hier guck
du mal haben wir hier irgendwas neues danke game ich muss das intro gucken verstehe ich
chat wart ihr auch so scharf drauf dieses intro jetzt nochmal anzugucken ich bin echt
froh dass sie mir das zeigen jetzt kann ich sehen wie cool wir da reingeflogen werden
mit dem Heli noch nie gesehen ok nice gut jetzt kann ich natürlich meine Waffe nicht
mal customize hat wunderbar funktioniert ist Battlefield endlich mal gut naja also in Battlefield
Maßstimmen nicht in Battlefield 2042 Maßstimmen ja und in so insgesamt Games Maßstimmen geht
so ich glaube wenn das Game eben in diesem Zustand rausgekommen wäre dann wären die
Leute zwar immer noch mega enttäuscht aber es wäre nicht so der der der der komplette
Brokkrepierer gewesen Leute ich trau mich da nicht rein ich hab Schiss pass mal auf nice
der war gut heute ich muss nachladen die kommen hier gleich rein ich habe ein Problem Leute
ich habe ich habe ein Problem kann man die Tür irgendwie zu machen nice was seriously
hallo ich möchte mich heilen ich will mich heilen hallo der midi Pen ist kaputt in ass
geballert ok hätte hätte ich mich da ein bisschen wäre ich da ein bisschen disziplinierter
gewesen auch mit Dauerfeuer hätten wir wieder viel mehr killen können Mensch dachte der
ist dauernd deswegen bin ich von ihm runter ich will da rein please nein was macht der
Kelder was ist das für ein Spawn Mensch das ist ja sonst wo
ist der Typ macht das gleiche wie ich das hatte ich mir auch gerade vor das war mein
eigentlicher Plan nicht genug Headshots ok ich gehe ich komme wieder raus
da kommt was kommt dir was durch
die Schneiber Dudes mann wisst ihr was richtig nice wäre ich erzähl euch mal was ich erzähl
euch mal was so als Boomer ich erzähl euch mal was es gab eine Zeit da konnte man sich
Server selbst installieren für Spiele und nachdem man quasi dann selbst bestimmen konnte
was auf dem Server den man selbst bezahlt und selbst administriert und selbst gekauft
hatten dass man bestimmen konnte was darauf läuft da konnte man dann so Sachen machen
wie zum Beispiel ein Sniper Limit ok alles klar man musste morgen arbeiten gar nicht
habe jetzt Urlaub für das restliche ja könnt ihr euch das vorstellen man konnte man konnte
auf dem Server den man kauft und bezahlt und betreibt und administriert und Geld rein steckt
machen was man wollte das ist das ist das ist unvorstellbar ich weiß aber es war so
hallo was zum kannst du mal liegen bleiben Kollege ins Bressack wieso machst du keinen
Portal Server Portal Server Sacken und so Sachen wie Sniper Limit kannst du alle gescheit umsetzen
Shit hier ist ganz schön was los
aber es sind alles Legacy Features ich weiß ich weiß gibt es nicht mehr die Technologie
die Technologie ist einfach noch nicht da aber dafür ist die Technologie da
und da gab es dann zum Beispiel so coole Plugins wie einen Balancer der die Leute nach anhand
der Punkte für die nächste Runde einsortiert oder du hattest Plugins zum Beispiel das du
Sniper Limits machen konntest du konntest Sniper zwar verbieten aber das fand ich nicht gut
ich finde schon dass die Recon Klasse eine Daseinsberechtigung im Spiel hat
Mensch Alter das kannst du hier immer den Kopf raus stecken die Sniper hat selbstverständlich
eine Daseinsberechtigung in dem Spiel aber es wäre halt sinnvoll wenn du beispielsweise
Rush 12 gegen 16 vs 16 spielst wenn nicht 13 Leute Sniper wären ich bin der Meinung
das tut dem Gameplay gut DICE sieht das anders DICE möchte nicht das Server Betreiber das
den Spielern vorschreiben können was sie zu spielen haben und deswegen haben sie das
Feature abgeschafft darf keine Kills mehr machen Kills machen
ist untersagt ist meiner Herkel hinter dir ist einer in der Korb
ich dachte ich habe die Leute habe ich warum habe ich nie war für nee aber das ist die
richtige ich bin verwirrt die sehen sich so ähnlich die sehen sich so ähnlich ich dachte
ich habe das Assault Rifle ich habe ja die SMG dabei
kann halt auch von links einer kommen ok Leute wisst ihr was wir jetzt machen
das wollte ich nicht machen ich wollte eigentlich zu C1 rüber
in der Korb genau ich wollte eigentlich zu C1 rüber weil ich denke da ist wenig und
hier in diesem also ich vermute die beste Taktik ist tatsächlich sich ein bisschen aufzubinden
C1 rüber zu gehen so dass die alle denken sie müssen jetzt C1 Defenden und dann kriegst
ihr weil das Warenhaus ist enorm schwer für mich einzunehmen ich sehe hier nichts
da fliegt er auf die Mensch auf die Range ist es nicht so geil
Leute danach Rush danach Rush das ist mir zu undurchsichtig brauchen wir wieder Mid-Range
Achtung sobald wir da raus gehen kriegen wir auf den Sack ich höre sie schon ich höre
sie schon pass mal auf in der Korb wieder ok komm mal vielleicht können wir in Gachi
Bus Gachi Bus Leute wenn ich auch nicht richtig getroffen habe dachte wir könnten jetzt richtig
so von hinten rein fahren in die Defens
das ist gar kein Kopf gewesen ich dachte es ist ein Kopf
sah aus wie ein Kopf hinter mir
no krieg ich nen Rats alter das wär schon geil
das wär schon geil Leute das wär schon richtig Pogge
Prinz Bressack auf nee der der macht das der macht das
der der ist high IQ player
ich war blöd ich hätte doch das Magazin wechseln können man kann auch das Magazin wechseln
und dann ist die Waffe wieder voll
nee ich geh an C1 rein Hostile Forces sind am Start
ok gut hat nicht so funktioniert wie ich mir das vorgestellt hab
den hab ich nicht gesehen man kann bestimmt nicht gerätst werden oder oder oder oder
Green Concrete nice
Ehrenmann nennt man sowas doch heute oder
richtiger Ehrenmann
alter meine Güte in jeder Ecke
ich hoffe wir können danach eine Containermap spielen
ich hätte jetzt richtig Bock auf eine Containermap Leute
ich hab zu wenig Container gehabt
auch mehr mehr Container zu wenig
achso das ist gar kein
Habt ihrs gesehen der Schuss ist einfach direkt durch den Gegner gegangen
Hitboxen gibt es nicht
Hitbox not found
not found gibt es nicht
brauchen wir nicht
oh das war natürlich super krass
aim gott am Start wieder
Hitbox 404
Mensch
glaub das kriegen wir nicht
gehen wir mal hier drauf und gucken ob wir das Defenden können
Mist
ah shit der hat die deutlich bessere Pose gehabt
der hätte ich wenn schon den Kopf treffen müssen
ey guck mal der Typ 3 und 30 Revives
der geht ja mal zur Sache
zum Glück hat er noch schlechter getroffen wie ich
guck mal mein hier ging nicht durch
haben wirs wir habens oder
wir habens nice
easy hätte ich gar nicht gedacht
hätte ich gar nicht gedacht dass wir das hinkriegen
hat jemand gesehen wieviel Tickets noch übrig waren
Alter Mensch dieses Kackzeug
ich hab schon wieder vergessen wie man diesen ganzen Kram
Tee glaub ich
nee
ich hab nur wieder vergessen wie man das Spawn ich weiß gar nicht wie man das Spawn
Hallo hier ist was hier ist was drin
ach da steht ne Sentry gun
das ist halt wieder Cluster Fuck hoch 10 grade
wenn ich Glück habe
ooooh Prinz Pressack Ehrenmänner alles hier
Mist
1080Ti beste also zumindest lange Zeit
hat er mir gute Dienst hier geleistet die 1080Ti
ey Cluster Fuck man ich muss Rush spielen ich dreh durch
ja ok
vielleicht gewinnen wirs wenigstens wenigstens gucken dass wir die Runde noch hinbekommen
wär doch nice
das schaffen wir doch im Leben nicht
jawoll
raus Bunny Hopped
Horge
das hätte sonst nicht funktioniert
raus Bunny Hopped
ooooh Granate
ESL Movement ja
würde gern Gegner sehen wäre nice
Dankeschön
Gegner sehen wäre Pretty Horge
überhaupt was sehen wäre richtig
richtig Pork
Leute irgendwas sehen wäre mega nice
ein mega nicees Feature
was sehen bestimmt auch Legacy
alles Legacy
ja man will auch schon was sehen in so nem Game
kann ich schon verstehen dass die Schweden keine
Ressourcen drauf verschwenden
genau hat es jetzt nicht weiter funktioniert
du startest das
oh fuck zu spät gesehen
ich hätt nicht auf dem Chat kommen müssen
du startest das Game jetzt auch mal nice
kannst ja nachjoinen du hast mich ja glaub ich in der Liste
Kompass
ich würde gerne mein Crapling
ey
please lasst mich doch einfach normal irgendwo mal so über den
über den Weg laufen
WTF man
ich weiß auch nicht mal wo der Typ war
ich seh nix
Alter wo kam denn der jetzt her
es ist Abzug Clusterfuck gerade
ploppt irgendwas rein
ne der ist weg ne
please heilen hallo hallo ey der hilft uns nicht
so kaputt das ist verbackt seit dem Patch
du kriegst Damage oder weiß ich ob seit dem Patch
ist aber ich hab den Eindruck vorher gings besser
du kriegst Damage und den kleinsten Hauch eines Damages
und er bricht ab
jemand chat chat ihr müsst mir mal kurz helfen
habt ihr noch ne Ahnung wie man diese Sachen spawnt
diese Hunde und das Zeug
wisst ihr noch wie das geht
A Clusterfuck von jeder Ecke ist irgendwas
Q halten und nach oben wischen was
B ok das muss ich jetzt ausprobieren
ok Moment ich teste das jetzt mal
B aha und jetzt
was ist jetzt
he macht das jetzt was achja es hat gebackt verstehe
es hat nicht funktioniert
kann ja schon mal passieren
ne da kann ich nicht facen das funktioniert nicht
Achtung hinter den Amazon Roboter
ok raus Rush schalt es dann mal aus
boah das war anstrengende Runde
aber die Leute gingen wieder gut ab bei uns
gehen wir mal online
im Spiel
ich würde gerne die Lobby verlassen
wäre sehr nice wenn das funktioniert
oh es ist es bestimmt weg
ok also Rush auf gehts
haben wir eine Lobby wie macht man in dem Game ne Lobby
ehm
ea friends achja da isser
ok Rush auf gehts bam
Rush Spearhead ich glaube wir haben nicht eine Runde
bisher Rush Spearhead gespielt
glaub das kam bis jetzt noch nicht
vielleicht jetzt
Caspian Border ein Klassiker
wobei ich die nie gefeiert hab
viele Leute eines ihrer Lieblingsmaps schlechthin
ich fand die zu fahrzeuglastig
ah da spielen wir auf jeden fall das Ding
ach Gott jetzt hat sich wieder nicht gemerkt was ich ausgerüstet hab
oh ich hör da rechts was
so krass
ja die Battlefield 4 Variante
kann ich schon dunkel dran erinnern
ok was ist hier los
Leute Leute was so von wo vor wo ist hier was
ich bleck nicht mehr durch zu viel hier
aber erstmal die Leute wiederbeleben auf jeden fall
oh mann fuck
hey Leute wirds Zeit für Stinger geiern
wird es Zeit für Stinger geiern
ich glaube aber es wird Zeit für Stinger geiern
wobei da müssen wir nicht mal Stinger geiern
da können wir auch
da haben wir aber kein Heal mehr
ey wir müssen Stinger geiern
damit wird das nichts
ja ja wir geiern jetzt Stinger
ja ja mach mich blatt ich muss Stinger geiern
nein nicht wiederbeleben
ja ja komm um die Ecke
komm um die Ecke
ok Stinger wo ist die Stinger
es muss Stinger bobt werden
man kann die von Beginn an nur setzen wenn du die im Editor auswählst
ok eigentlich muss ich aber Jets nicht abschießen
Jets sind ziemlich useless in dem Spiel
Achtung Achtung er will jetzt auf mich
das wird einfach hyper gestingert hier
ha ha zu früh geflamed äh geflährt
ey hallo wie oft noch please
wie oft muss ich noch treffen
mehr
heute heule mag uns das Spiel nicht
nämlich was anderes
nehmen wir mal das Teil
ok mein Motion Sensor hier hin
ist hier was
glaub das ist hier nichts mehr ha
sind alle down
nein das soll mir recht sein
ok oh ne ich hab ja kein Heal mehr
shit shit shit shit
äh äh Moment Moment
an was genau bin ich jetzt gestorben
konnte konnte der Battle für Loki gegen jemand folgen
verbrannt ich hab überhaupt kein Damage bekommen
oh das ist ein Panzer
oh ich hör was neben mir
die Zapfsäule ist hochgegangen
das kann natürlich sein
ich finde das haben sie in Battlefield 3 ganz gut gemacht
ey dieses kack Ding man
wenn Teammates irgendwas in Luft gesprengt haben
dann hat es dir kein Damage gemacht
wie viel hält das Ding noch aus
ja alter hör mal auf zu pingen man
krieg dich ab
wer auch immer was gewesen ist
scheiße man heute ist echt nichts
heut kommste spawn dead
eins haben wir noch hier
nope was
hier vorne kommen wir nicht mehr rein
es geht mit dem Finger ab
stop pingen du
ja soll er
soll er machen
ist halt nur ist halt nur leicht nervig
da kommt ein Panzer
aber jetzt hab ich damit gerechnet da kommt jetzt gleich dieses komische
wie heißt denn das Ding überhaupt
dieses Landehelikopter Ding
da war was ich hab was gesehen
ja das ist gewesen
jetzt ist es nicht mehr da
Gegner?
die Gegners
Osprey ist das ein Osprey
wie toll ja
da ist was
komm mal
das Ding ist für die Range nicht gemacht man
kann man motion sensor rüberschmeißen
da hat er wirklich
Alter es gibt doch nicht es gibt es doch nicht
ja also das ist nix nix ist das ist nix
das ist auch so ein Ding meint ihr die haben sich das
wirklich gut überlegt mit diesem Ammo wechseln
ich meine es ist ja ganz nice dass du unterschiedliche
unterschiedliche
ach komm mal da ich kann geiern
unterschiedliche Muni hast
Leute habt ihr Schüsse gesehen von dem Typ überhaupt
bist du ja team high sens oder super low sens
so so mittel mittig
also ich hab 800 dpi und 20 20 in game sense und ich hab aber nur 90 fof
nur 90 fof ich bin kein 105 fof enjoyer
ne die werden dann im Klassen also die das Klassen System ist nicht wirklich ein Klassen
System
das bleibt mit den specialist die haben es ja schon erklärt was wir machen wollen
dass mit den specialist bleibt
hallo
wer hat sich gedacht dass dieser heli eine gute Idee ist
wer dachte nice der ist der ist geil den brauchen wir
ok loss
800 dpi 20 in game das ist nicht sonderlich niedrig also ich hab ungefähr jetzt so einen
70 prozent des mousepads
normalerweise habe ich ziemlich genau 360 einmal übers mousepad
ich hab sie nicht richtig eingestellt
jetzt habe ich ungefähr 70 prozent des mousepads
weiß nicht warum
es hier anders ist
müssten eigentlich genau die gleichen settings sein
hier das war nix
mal gucken was für ne map jetzt kommt
also ich gehe raus wenn caspian border attack noch mal ist das ist mir zu resident sleeper
wobei attack könnte man tatsächlich mal spielen
mal schauen
wisst ihr was nice ist
dass ich jetzt urlaub hab für das restliche jahr
ich hab es noch gar nicht so richtig realisiert
wir könnten jetzt theoretisch jeden tag sieben stunden streben
was ich nicht machen werde weil ich es nicht durchhalte
boomer boomer alt und boomer müde und boomer brain macht da nicht mehr mit
und bestimmt nicht mit battlefield das ist halt das ding
oh die neue alte neue map
war das war das die erste
warte mal ja das ist die erste das ist die erste season map gewesen
gär
zweite season map war das schiff
so dritte season map ist jetzt die map mit den zwei häusern drauf
so viel urlaub
gut heißt aber auch ich hatte das ganze jahr über kein urlaub
guck mal das serious max der hat sogar seine
seine karte customized hier
konnte ich mich nicht dazu durchringen bisher bei dem game
Leute was hab ich denn eigentlich für ne waffe
ist das
das ist immer noch die smg oder
ja das ist die smg
deswegen ging das deswegen hab ich über range auch grad nichts auf die reihe gekriegt
mann ich hab die ganze zeit smg gespielt die sieht für mich sah für mich aus wie
mein wie mein assault rifle guckt euch mal habt ihr habt ihr euch die
nee
moment sind meine attachments verbackt
Leute die attachments sind verbackt
das ist nicht das was ich normalerweise hab
super jetzt habe ich natürlich das intro wieder komplett verschissen sodass
uns hier im halben spawn kritischer hase ist da jawoll endlich der kritische
hase
ich hätte direkt reingemusst mit
grappling hook und sowas
alle ich möchte mich heilen aufhaken ich nur ich habe kein heal dabei gehabt
dankeschön ich bin blöd ich hab noch die stinger dabei man
ein richtiger stinger noob
oh gott alda das darfst du ja kein zeigen guckt euch das an
ok wir müssen hier unten rein
hyper aim war das gerade hier
ok ich sollte mal vielleicht die stinger raus packen ich wollte nämlich gerade
warum kann ich mich nicht heilen warum kann ich mich nicht heilen
ich würde dich ja retten ich hab bloß das doofe gefühl sobald ich dich retze
ok kritischer hase hat sich ausgehasst
auf der seite ist einer
legehennen legehennen ist drin leute legehennen läuft
hallo please please heal please heal danke danke
wusste ich doch dass da was ist
nein nein nicht das tor aufmachen man
da können sie uns doch von der seite in ass gachi basin
so hier haben wir jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen glück
ist das game aktuell gut spielbar
nein aber es ist besser spielbar und ich sage euch wenn es in diesem
in diesem zustand rausgekommen wäre wäre es immer noch eine enttäuschung gewesen
aber nicht ganz so krass
was ich mal ein bisschen mehr üben würde sodass ich wieder halbwegs was treffe
dann könnten wir da komplett durchrasieren hier
warum kann ich dir nicht retzen
white no rest
auf der anderen seite mann alter
was haben die gegner für ultra mann ich ich ich mach da den kopf raus
und ich bin direkt von zwei gehittet
wir haben es schaffen können
habe gerade erst mitgekriegt dass du mit einigen gesagen bekannten gesicht wirklich mit wem
dann
wem kennt man davon grithase ist das aporette echte wer ist wem kennt man dann
wie sagt keiner was
macht das preview aus weil das manchmal ein paar mehr fps bringt
aus dem chat ach was war dann da
gibt es nicht mehr ok
ich spiele nur mit einem
mod check
hast doch spaß
war nicht umsonst das game
hast du noch die gtx 1080 ti ja
aber december ist zeit für neuen rechner
wie fandest du den capture the flag mode in battlefield 3
war das nicht in battlefield 4
nee in battlefield 4 war dieser komische bombenmodus den keiner gespielt hat
ehrlich gesagt ich kann mich an den capture the flag modus von battlefield 3 überhaupt
nicht mehr erinnern
ganz ehrlich ich glaube auch nicht dass es sinnvoll ist noch mehr spielmode hier einzubauen
weil das wird doch kein e-sport game mehr
was ist eigentlich aus incursion geworden und ihrer komischen e-sport ambition diese
da hatten
gibt es nicht mehr oder
hat sich
hat sich aus e-sported
ja also wie gesagt ich werde mir eine neue grafik gerade holen neue cpu neue alles muss
jetzt nicht die einen sagen ich hol mir komplett neuen rechner im december
die einzige sache wo ich mir noch wirklich auf was ist da auf der anderen Seite unschlüssig
ich bin
die haben mich gesehen
pass auf jebaited jebaited
wie
ich wollte eigentlich aufs dach und ihn von da oben
serious marks bist du rausgeflogen
leute ich kann nicht nachkampf machen
mein nachkampf ist kaputt
geht nicht
nachkampftaste ist kaputt
hi iq platz zu spät
meine nachkampftaste ist kaputt
komplett
nexe der q ok
normalerweise ist es relativ defender heavy
wo ist denn hier was
ist nicht mehr moment moment moment die sind dahinten schon
haben wir den dude
ich rätste ich rätste ich rätste ich
bl etti
gegenseitig ges체가
eim gegeneinander gespray und
meine waffe ist zwar schneller 1999
ganz gut festgesetzt, da muss man jetzt aufpassen, sonst ist B auch ratzfatz weg.
Nein!
Pass mal auf, Trick 17, Trick 17!
Durchs Dach!
Dach stellts!
Ok, ist nichts mehr.
Ich hab den Motion Sensor hingeschmissen, ist nichts mehr da.
Außer, oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
Oh Panzer! Der schießt gleich die Wand weg!
Oh! War so klar.
Oh, mehr kann ich nicht machen.
Mehr geht nicht.
Ja, mit der AFK Dude.
Hallo! Please! Gadgets! Einfach mal funktionieren!
Nice, Dankeschön, GG!
Der konnte ernsthaft legen.
Der trifft mich nicht, du triffst mich nicht, du triffst mich nicht.
Easy, du triffst mich nicht. Und weg hier.
Weg hier, weg hier.
Keine Zeit zu razen.
Pass mal auf, High IQ Play.
Shit.
Muss kurz warten.
Sobald ich nämlich rauskomm.
Ich hör dir ja hier schon.
Ok, ne.
Oder auch nicht.
Ok, ok.
Da ist was.
Aber gut, haben wir gut defendet.
Alter, der Panzer da drüben geht mir auf den Sack, Mann.
Oh ne, ich hab mich schon wieder gelegt.
Was soll ich denn noch machen?
Echt zu viel Legehände hier.
Keine Chance ist verloren.
Jetzt kommt Häuserstellz.
Danke für den Revive, aber...
Das hat jetzt nichts gebracht.
Außer, dass der Typ noch mal eine Runde Multi Double Kill.
Alter, jetzt darf ich wieder Nahkampf machen.
Das ist ja sehr nett.
Sehr nett von euch, dass ich das wieder machen darf.
Gut gemacht, gut gemacht, EA.
Ich stehe hier etwas ungünstig.
Ist das die Drohne da oben, Leute?
Boah, Mann, die hält viel zu viel aus.
Alter, wer hat das Balanced?
Dummeste Balance aller Zeiten, Mann.
Die Drohne hält viel zu viel aus.
Die Drohne ist richtig gut, aber die kann auch nicht 5, 6 Schuss aushalten.
Was ist das für eine dumme Designentscheidung, Mensch?
Na gut, was heißt dumme Designentscheidung?
Das ist vieles dumme an dem Game.
Da hat sich nie keiner Gedanken drüber gemacht.
Richtig hängen geblieben.
Das Ding war quasi fast One-Hit in BC2.
Und so muss es auch sein.
Es muss quasi One-Shot sein.
Unschlussig, wo ich hin soll.
Sterben wollen sie auch nicht mehr.
Du scheinst.
Vielleicht kriegen wir da jetzt was.
Ich hab da oben was gehört.
In the bobs.
Ja, please, come on.
Okay, so hab ich.
Ich war auch zu viel im Spawn.
Da musste mich irgendwann mal einer erwischen.
Okay, wir stellen es jetzt mal rauf.
Wir sind mal mutig.
Wir sind wahrscheinlich instant down da oben drauf.
Ja, das war so klar, man.
Aber ich sag euch eins.
Als Defender einfach reinspawnen, was das Zeug hält.
Das ist der größte Vorteil, den man gegenüber den Attackern hat.
Dann haben wir endlich Tickets.
Das hier für die Camper Nest wieder.
Komm mal, wir haben es fast schon geschafft.
Oh, oh.
Ich hör hier was.
Irgendwas labert hier um mich drum herum.
Waren das Gegner?
Waren das meine?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Da hinten hat einer einen Minipack hingeschmissen.
Das muss ein Gegner sein.
Okay.
Ich hoffe du warst der Einzige.
Danke für der Minipack.
Map Awareness
Hier, high IQ.
Was ist das?
Da fliegt ein Panzer.
Das war der Turm vom Panzer, der da geflogen ist.
Nein!
Sie haben geahmt!
Während wir da vorne Gegner gekillt haben.
Nein!
Der Typ ist nicht auf der Map drauf, by the way.
Guck mal auf die Map, den Gegner gibt's nicht.
Den Typ gab's nicht, mein Teammate.
Oh, oh, es wird voll, Leute, es wird voll.
Ich camp hier drin jetzt ein bisschen ab.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, Leute.
Oh, oh, hier ist ganz schön viel los.
Spam!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, gehst du weg?
Trommelmagazin.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Ich hab Schiss, man.
Leute, ich muss hier weg, ich muss hier weg, ich muss hier weg.
Okay, kipp.
Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt stürmen sie das Haus.
Ich bleib mal kurz liegen, bis ich gucken kann, ob noch Leute da sind.
Ihr müsst mich nicht ressen.
Ihr sterbt bei mir, wenn ihr mich resst.
Ich, ich release.
Nicht, ich will die Leute nicht jebaiten.
Der Spraychamp, ja.
Richtig nice reingesprayed.
Nice reingesprayed.
das ist schon 21h56 also in rush geht die Zeit wirklich
deutlich schneller rum kruf elektrik dankeschön für den sub kurz schauen ich
soll ich habe bestimmt wieder die hälfte an subscriptions vergessen heute
wen hatten wir denn die jane dankeschön leute hier massive subscriptions ich sehe es hier btm world
und jetzt kruf elektrik ich drauf geachtet zu beschäftigt gewesen mal gucken was als nächstes
kommt war immer davon abhängig ob wir noch eine runde spielen oder nicht
leute ich hatte heute ein termin mit meinem chef ist zwar nichts rausgekommen aber wisst ihr was
er mir lustiges erzählt hat ihm wurde mein schneegarten video also mein durch den durch
den schnee laufen im garten video auf youtube empfohlen stelle ich das mal vor oder muss ich
sagen ja das ist das unsinnigste video keine ahnung warum youtube diesen kram empfiehlt
dem wurde ernsthaft mein schnee video empfohlen warum auch immer das 1,2 millionen views hat ich
habe es bis heute nicht verstanden ich hoffe wir sind attacker auf noch mal defense habe ich
keinen bock und auf bots habe ich auch keinen bock wir sind attacker sehr schön die spielen
wir noch das spielen wir noch attacker sind aber noch bots aber uns in bots bei den gegnern sind
keine bots ok das heißt wenn ich auf was schießen dann ist es echt aber wenn die gegner auf was
bei uns schießen dann ist es nicht zwangsläufig echt so eine blöde mechanik aber man kommt schon
schnell vorwärts ok nice können wir hier einfach rein
habe ich den pp gottmann
ok das können wir tatsächlich kriegen
nach der runde gehe ich auch ja danach ist bettgetime für uns alle chat gleich ist bettgetime
sagen wir wollen die mich verarschen
warum ist das rush objective ein klima kondensator ja die schweden sind hauptbetroffene mit vom
klimawandel wer weiß was da los ist vielleicht haben die gewissen hasst gegen klimaanlagen
die schweden guck mal was da ein eis abschmilzt die haben sich gedacht da muss man ein zeichen
setzen ich hoffe es kommt keiner noch in de bobs ich weiß nicht genau wo die sind ich habe
da was gesehen der ist dauer ok
da ist was der typ kotzt habe ich schon zum zwanzigst mal gekillt oder so den dude hier
oh was ist hier der kotzt den habe ich irgendwie zwanzigst mal im folge schon gekillt
also wir waren auch gar nicht da es wäre nice wenn es funktioniert
davor war er nicht dauernd
der ist ja mal gut jetzt alter
oh muni leer
ok ich getroffen spray ge richtig rein gespray gesprüht und gebetet
so wie kommen wir da jetzt gescheit hin
ich wollte das kann ich runter
ich habe ich nicht gesehen aber da holt mich auch keiner ich lege im off
bester sport exquisite ich verstehe es aber ich bin blind hätte man eigentlich sehen
kann
dass wir jetzt umdrehen und nicht zu begehen
in dieser fall doch typ der kotzt alter das ist irgendwie das 22 mal jetzt oder so wo
ich den folge gekillt habe der typ ist wirklich rage fast wieder fast wieder
also nicht nur die runde nicht nur die runde letzte runde auch
ok ganz blöde hier wir können auch gar nicht weiter revive ge hier an dem müll beteilige
ich mich gar nicht
hier beteilige ich mich gar nicht dran ich hoffe die sehen mich nicht
und tschüss ich bin hier weg leute da war ich nicht mit mist kommen sie auch schon hin
hallo ich will mich heilen heilen gibt's nicht
das ist kein gegner sieht aber aus wie den kopf oder
ok achten achten die
ok mal gucken von wo sie kommen ist ja gut ist ja gut
meine güte aber wir haben es wir haben es
hier kommt was hier ist was
fast fast werden fast noch durchgehen können aber jetzt haben wir halt den nachteil dass
die alle auf b gucken das ist halt immer so ein rush so wenn die
maps nicht gescheit gemacht sind
was ist nicht
wo ist denn hier diese fucking tue hier
jetzt lade ich gerade in dem rätts mich leute rätts mich also kannst du sie rätten wir
brauchen mehr leute hier macht keiner
aber wir haben es wahrscheinlich wir sollten es also ich denke wir sollten es haben
das stimmt natürlich nicht
ich glaube die hat man also die habe ich selten gehabt die platform in rush
20er tick rate kacke
bin ja der typ bin ja der gleiche typ was
war da nicht immer einer
sind alle sind alle der doch wo ist denn der in dem plan
ist er hier drin was auch immer
um
Raumpfalz Salvo.
Ich fasse es nicht den fucking ziel fünf man
wäre dead gewesen ist hier nicht was zum durchlaufen gibt es eigentlich silence
in dem spiel das man nicht gesehen wird ich bin unschuldig ich habe gar kein plan von dem game
eigentlich ich ich warte mal kurz bis die leute reingespornet sind
dankeschön dass das so gut funktioniert hat
da hinten steht warum steht man denn da im spawn und guckt in eine richtung mensch wir
haben es aber glaube ich glaube wir kriegen es in b ist das trott und easy win easy win
so muss es sein outstanding performance gut dass die soldaten so unterschiedlich aussehen
waren wir wenigstens erst das squad ok objektiv des trott erstes ob das ergibt wenig sinn
ich habe glaube ich gar nichts gelegt diese runde aber wenn das game meint das kann er
nicht unrecht haben so habe ich was habe ich denn gelegt echt was habe ich denn gelegt
das erste habe ich nicht gelegt habe ich doch das in diesem komischen in dem häuschen habe
ich gelegt stimmt gar nicht mehr dran gedacht ja okay nice da hätten wir es ja wieder geschafft
für heute morgen gucken wir uns mal überlegt gerade gucken wir uns denn morgen an
also ich werde auf jeden fall jetzt wieder mehr stream sonn nicht unbedingt battlefield
ja habe ich auf jeden fall wieder mehr stream sonn weil komplett urlaub bis januar pc teile
oh ja das müssten wir tatsächlich machen mal fertig bauen weil ich bin immer noch
unschlussig ob wasserkühlung oder nicht oder ob 1000 oder ob 13.900 oder 13.700
und dann einfach luftkühlung black friday deals brausen haben freitag dann es macht
keinen sinn black friday week bei amazon es ist keine week und es ist nicht nur black
friday aber halt black friday week aktuell wirst ja überall folges per mit black friday
deals black friday week dann kommt als nächstes wann gibt es noch cyber monday gibt es ja
dann auch noch und die deals sind halt keine richtigen deals teilweise teurer heute wurde
wieder ein iphone empfohlen was mehr kostet als die neuen top modelle ja genau die angebote
sind keine angebote ja ist so ich stelle schon mal kurz für morgen mal auf just just chatting
um krieg wait heißt das stream dann einfach da ins sofa und das ist aber krass viel ich
meine das sind auch schweizer franken ist ja noch mal mehr ja die habe ich auch überlegt
aber ich müsste mir die ganz große holen wenn ich überhaupt 13.900 hole ich weiß nicht
bin bin da noch sehr unschlüssig wir sehen uns morgen bis dann machts gut see u